mac way joins the show it's great to
have you on man congratulations on this
thing
finally coming out we've been hearing
rumblings about it in hollywood for a
long time how do you feel that we're on
the verge of untold
finally being shared with the world it's
exciting it it it has i feel like that
is if if we have like any rumors about
our show it's always that which is like
man this is still the same one you guys
are working on
i was like yeah man still the same one
um but no we are like unbelievably
thrilled and excited to finally get
these
out can't wait for tuesday for our
malice in the palace episode to drop
it's gonna be fun
i remember we first connected at
sundance for the battered bastards of
baseball right
and then you went on and did this
incredible series wild wild country
which is just so
fascinating and then now you have this
project and honestly it was kind of like
the great white whale this idea
oh the way brothers are doing this
sports thing with netflix and nobody
really knew
what it was everybody was fans of your
previous work but what was it about this
series what was it about this
approach to having multiple stories
uh that really grabbed you and inspired
you as a filmmaker
yeah absolutely you kind of nailed it
you know our first doc was on
a netflix documentary on a minor league
baseball team called the portland
mavericks that my grandfather
had owned and that was really our debut
documentary in our first documentary
and then we kind of right after that
jumped head first into something that
was like 180 degrees in the
different direction you know the
rashness purim story of this cult that
had built this hundred million dollar
utopian city in oregon and kind of
ignited
warfare out there and then once that
came out you know we had like a lot of
options i think like truthfully we were
probably pitched like every cult story
under the sun
so after a while that kind of our eyes
started to glaze over a bit
um but sports is just like we're huge
fans of sports documentary huge sports
fans ourselves
um i was a very mediocre left-handed
baseball pitcher that topped out at like
78 miles an hour so maybe there was some
wish fulfillment on my part
to get to talk to real professional
athletes and and work with them
um and netflix was a great partnership
like basically we started out with our
marty fish documentary
but ultimately just expanded it into uh
five
five sports documentary films this is
volume one um
and we wanted to kind of make a big play
a big splash in sports talks and see
see if we can add something to the
conversation mcclain wade joins the show
the emmy-winning producer and director
part of this new series untold for
netflix ben line's in for rich on the
rich eisen show
our super producer chris brockman has a
marty fish connection
yeah it's not great it's not great marty
fish as you know phenomenal golfer in
addition to being
an accomplished tennis player played in
a charity tournament with marty a couple
years ago
uh he single annually led us to first
place
which won us a free travel bag that's
awesome
my first marty fish story is that uh
i was like all right let's meet up and
he's like great let's go to katsu and
brentwood
he's like i eat lunch there every day
and i i was like all right maybe he's
been like a little hyperbolic but like
we go in and the place isn't even open
it feels like they've like specifically
opened it
for him and he gets to order the marty
fish roll he has his own sushi roll
named after him at that katsu
i was pretty blown away but he's been an
unbelievably fun guy to work with uh
yeah our connection with him is like
weirdly our one of our best buddies from
high school is the american
uh tennis player sam querrey and we
don't talk about this often but we were
uh
embarrassingly a part of the samurai
which was sam querrey's
uh fan group we would follow sam around
at tennis tournaments and cause a bunch
of problems and
and we had a lot of ruckus uh but we got
to know marty a bit there and we're
super excited to partner up with him on
this one
mac way joins the show i was saying
before you jumped on i had a chance to
watch the mouse at the palace one and i
love documentaries that i think going
into them
i know everything about it i remember
watching it live
i know we're on our test i've talked to
stephen jackson about this i'm a
basketball historian i know this
but you're able to show us different
sides of these men different sides of
this story
that i found myself just connected to it
in a completely different way
what was it about this story that
obviously inspired you as a filmmaker
but what challenges were there
when you knew there were guys in the
audience like me who were like wait a
minute i know everything about this
already
yeah for sure it's a great question and
like ultimately i think it came down to
a couple things one was just like
our faith it's similarly like i remember
when malice and the palace happen it's
one of the few sports events that you
can kind of
share those stories about with other
people about where you were and what you
were doing when it all happened
but really it started with our
conversations with jermaine o'neill you
know who really wanted
had wanted to do something on this for
years um and it's really kind of where
the theme of untold came from and i feel
like the
the the subtext to untold is it's not
necessarily that these sports stories
haven't been covered like they've been
covered and talked about for sure
but at least talking to jermaine and
having faith in him and
ron and stephen jackson that they hadn't
been told through like their povs like
their perspective
and that doesn't necessarily mean that
we did these as puff pieces or anything
but we definitely tried to like edit
score uh put the audience on the journey
through like their lens and that's
ultimately what i'm
super proud about i think the other
thing that just drew us to this
is just like the unaired footage we were
able to get um
we were luckily filed the freedom of
information act with like the auburn
hills police department and they had
all these camera angles that were like
fascinating and things that i had never
seen on youtube and it was good quality
um and at that point we felt like all
right we have like some pretty awesome
unaired footage that's never been seen
we have these great characters who are
willing to be like raw uncensored
vulnerable
sometimes like at times they admit fault
but at times they feel like a lot of
blame got put on them as well
and we felt like all right we have
enough magic here to go make something
special
mack wade joins the show untold the new
documentary series on netflix premieres
next week finally after many years in
the works you hear rumblings about it in
hollywood
for a long time oh the way brothers
they're working on this cool new untold
thing
now it's finally coming out one of the
stories centers on caitlyn jenner and i
would imagine it's a challenge as a
filmmaker with a subject like that
to put the story to bed because i feel
like she's in the news continuing to
make news every week now uh what was it
about
her story that she really wanted to kind
of shine a light on because there's
obviously so much there when you're
talking about caitlyn jenner
yeah you know the interesting about
caitlyn is like she's one of the few
you know iconic celebrities i think in
our country where different generations
have so many different
i don't know if um opinions is the right
word but just different
like a different contextualization for
her you know like
for someone like my father or my mother
like they remember caitlyn that
you know 1976 montreal games you know
destroying the decathlon over 48 hours
breaking the world record
winning gold and then i think for like
our generation like honestly like it was
more of a keeping up with the
kardashians
like reality tv star like i i think i
had some understanding
of what she accomplished at the games
but didn't
really have a full you know idea of what
that story was
and then similarly the malice i mean
it's not the most exciting answer
in the world but ultimately like we went
to the ioc the olympic committee
and they just had like 30 hours of like
this pristine 16 millimeter film
following jenner around at the games um
we approached caitlyn and talked her and
she kind of expressed
you know a similar thing to what i
talked about which is like hey
for for the idea for her to go back and
talk about the blood sweat and tears and
her athletic performance
and what she did to win gold uh with our
footage felt like you know man this is a
this is a great
opportunity to kind of almost
re-contextualize one of the most famous
people in our country's origin story so
to speak
mack wade joins the show the series is
untold ben lyons in for rich on the rich
eisen show one of the five that are
coming out in this first
bundle you had a chance to direct uh
along with chapman called
crime and penalties tell me about this
one and this one is this is one of our
favorites
it's i i say it with a smile on my face
and a giggle in my voice because tonally
it's different
it's i think it's probably the most like
comical documentary we've ever made
which
it can be tough to to pull those off um
but it's essentially about
a man named jimmy galante who was a ma a
huge waste hauling
figure on the east coast rumors abound
that uh tony soprano was based off of
him
uh and he has this son named aj similar
to the show
um and aj was this high school obsessed
hockey player and
in the last game of his high school
career he rips his knee
uh tears his acl and can never play
hockey again
and so what does jimmy his father do uh
he buys him
a minor league hockey team in the united
hockey league of course they're called
the danbury trashers because of jimmy's
waste hauling business
um and he instills his 17 year old son
aj
as the president and general manager and
it's usually at that point that i like
to say and
madness ensues they were they were the
self-titled bad boys of hockey they
basically stacked their team
with bruisers and bullies and enforcers
and they just
uh violently beat up on teams and won
games and
it i don't want to give away the ending
of the dock too much but the federal
government comes in
gets involved and ultimately the team is
disbanded by the federal government
which i don't think has happened too
often in professional sports so
uh for us it was just too good of a
story and these characters and guys were
just too
too fun to uh too much fun not to work
with
corruption the federal government hockey
you've got mike del tufo's 10 bucks he's
in yeah man
is all in uh the battered bastards of
baseball
is one of my favorite sports docs in
recent memories i mentioned that
we connected out at sundance when you
guys premiered the film it's been a few
years now has there been talks of
maybe a scripted version of the story i
feel like it's so ripe
for a continuation of this world because
it's really unique time in baseball
history
wow man i'd be the first one to buy a
ticket and go see it
i would love for a scripted remake of
batter bastards
exactly like you said i love those
characters i love that setting northwest
1970s
the ballparks that these guys would play
and they take a bus to these games and
they ultimately just kind of
lived a dream or live their dream on
like a low level of professional
baseball
uh with really out any you know dreams
or illusions that they would make it to
the big leagues but they still find a
lot of happiness
i would love to see it get made we i out
of sundance we had partnered with a
company that had bought
the scripted rights and tried to get
into development it's it's it's crazy
you know we're in the documentary world
and i think like
90 of the reason why we're in that world
is because we can just go get our
cameras go call of people
go find interviews go get archived
footage and we can make these things
scripted world's a lot a lot lot more
pieces to navigate there uh but at the
end of the day we'd love to see that get
made
last thing i'll leave you with you
mentioned the idea of as a documentary
filmmaker feeling empowered where you
don't need to play the hollywood game
you can just go out there and shoot
something
now that you've immersed yourself in the
world of sports this five part series
makes its
debut next week another five episodes to
come hopefully by the end of the year or
very soon
are you trying to do something
completely out of sports next or are you
now
fully and great you know engulfed in the
world of sports storytelling do you see
that for your next project as well yeah
it's a great question i think that like
we chased the stories first you know i i
do think with with with untold um
we're really excited to hopefully build
something here that that that splashes
in and that people
dive into and watch and super excited
about volume one and volume two and
as long as it works for netflix we'll
keep making these for for definitely a
long time um definitely with the first
five
and and still working on it today uh
we're very hands on we had a great team
of collaborators directors
and editors and producers that really
all pulled these together uh but yeah no
i think i i think we're excited to still
keep our hand in this
in in this little uh sports industry uh
but hopefully
uh also find other stories that that
need to be told because we would be
always really excited to go do that as
well as someone who's a fan of your work
and just a fan
of the genre of sports storytelling i'm
so excited for this to finally
be coming out after all these years so
congratulations and we appreciate you
taking some time man
of course thanks so much for having me
joining the show part of the team
behind untold hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here